okay john corbett here this is why
tonight's such a big night for me on new
member night at the academy in 1980 1981
1982 and 1983 and four
my i was 18 years old and i just arrived
from whaling west virginia and my
girlfriend and i we lived in long beach
california and every it was on mondays i
think the oscars are still on monday
nights aren't they sunday they're
sundays now but at that time they were
on monday nights and they were always at
the dorothy chandler pavilion in
downtown l.a and we would leave long
beach around noon
get to dorothy chandler pavilion park
two blocks away and walk up into the
bleachers and watch
all the stars arrive for four years at
that time there were maybe
200 a couple 300 people up there
not like today where you wait and wait
and wait for a week and i have
scrapbooks at home of
of richard gere and
and
chevy chase and warren beatty and diane
keane and all these stars coming just
10
feet away and they would always smile
and i have stacks of these pictures back
in my mom's house in west virginia and
to be able to vote for the oscars now is
an amazing 30-year journey and i
couldn't be happier